today's show is sponsored by vincero
watches which is an american company
building
super premium wrist watches starting at
only about a hundred and fifty dollars
and they're giving you 15 off when you
go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link underneath
this video today's show
also sponsored by blinkist which is the
app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist totally
free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman that link is underneath the
video as well
we are really in an unprecedented
situation in american politics and
really in global politics in a number of
different ways
and we just don't know who we can
believe at this point in time
about donald trump's condition when it
comes to having contracted coronavirus
and being hospitalized since last week
the president of the united states just
four weeks plus one day
that's where we are today four weeks
plus one day from a presidential
election
is in the hospital with a case of
coronavirus the same coronavirus that he
and his administration have downplayed
for months
and even ridiculed joe biden for
taking seriously and wearing a mask and
distancing and having
small crowds at his events and in
addition to this
the trump administration is not coming
clean with the seriousness of donald
trump's condition now
i am not alleging that donald trump is
deathly ill
but what is abundantly clear from the
clips i'm going to play for you later
today
is that donald trump's doctors are not
and
have not been telling the truth about
donald trump's health situation from the
start
but to begin with let's cut through
all of the bs and speculation and
talking points
and just focus on what we know there are
two possibilities here
either donald trump is being given tons
of treatment
despite having almost no symptoms merely
as a precaution because he's the
president
which puts him at significant risk of
side effects and you'll hear why in a
moment
or his coronavirus is much more serious
than is being admitted or as a third
possibility
which i raise not because i believe it
but because i know there will be people
who will write to me and say
you know david the third possibility is
he doesn't really have coronavirus
and it's all a sham i don't believe that
that is the case i believe the political
r
it's not that he wouldn't lie about it
trump would lie about anything
it's that it is of unclear benefit to
fake having coronavirus i just don't
know that it would be
a guaranteed advantage in any way so i
don't think he would do it
what we know is that donald trump has
been in the hospital since friday
is overweight eats a terrible diet is in
his mid 70s has needed supplemental
oxygen as of this point we believe at
least two times
had a high fever at least at one point
and is being given
treatments that most people only get
when they are
much more serious why would the white
house try to
hide the seriousness of trump's
coronavirus if indeed that is what they
are doing well
for optics and for public relations
purposes and in fact by the time
you hear this show today it is actually
possible that donald trump
may have already been discharged from
walter reed and be back at the white
house
i'm going to say more about that a
little bit later now
the first red flag that we saw these are
not my opinions but these are
the opinions of doctors dr john torres
explained on nbc that trump
receiving the steroid dexamethasone is a
major
red flag that trump is sicker than the
white house
is saying why because dexamethasone
for coronavirus is only given when
patients have a certain degree of lung
involvement that typically would only
happen seven to ten days into the
disease
donald trump was given dexamethasone
over the weekend
just a couple of days into treatment
that is not good
number two once you read through
the nonsense of donald trump's dr sean
conley's
public statements and focus not on the
tone
but on the facts dr celine gunder
explains that trump having a fever
and an oxygen saturation level below 94
on friday
is not mild coronavirus as dr gander
explains when you have oxygen saturation
below 94
that is considered severe covid period
going further as dr gaunder explained on
cnn
trump was given remdessevere
remdessevere and dexamethazone
are serious medications given to
patients with severe covid
and as dr eric ding explains
dexamethasone
is typically for patients either in the
icu
or on ventilators and sometimes for
patients on oxygen who are
going in the wrong direction in advance
of possible ventilation the nih
guidelines on dexamethasone which are on
the screen for our audience
are not recommended for mild or even
moderate cases
so when we heard yesterday and the david
as we heard that donald trump
might be discharged today and that may
even have happened by the time that this
show gets published
it simply doesn't line up with the facts
that we have
so if donald trump is indeed or has been
discharged today
it would very likely be for optics
purposes the hypothesis would be
again they've taken the last few days to
set up
better medical facilities at the white
house with the goal being to transfer
donald trump there
uh and to be able to provide care for a
more serious case
at the white house but it would be like
being at the hospital
the other possibility again because
we're working constantly with incomplete
information from dishonest actors
is that all there is just some bigger
picture lie that is being told here and
again
this is an administration that has lied
about everything including donald
trump's health for four years
this is the skepticism that we should be
coming in with
and case in point they have been
dishonest at
every single opportunity nobody's saying
trump is going to die
nobody's saying trump is in the icu or
on a ventilator but there have been no
reasonable explanations as to how it is
that donald trump
has a mild case it's always been mild
and every day they say he's improving
despite the fact that he's had fever has
needed oxygen at least twice
had an oxygen saturation below 94 and i
believe in the 80s which is
very serious we'll talk about that later
received an unapproved antibody cocktail
andrem de severe and dexamethasone is it
simply because he's the president
starting to be hard to believe this is
whatever your belief about trump is and
mine is
that he's horrible it is a stressful and
scary moment
that we are living through at this time
we're going to talk next about the lying
and the implications and everything else
so
now i do want to play for you just some
clips of donald trump's dr
sean conley deceiving
and juking and disorienting the public
over the weekend about donald trump's
health
so on saturday morning sean conley came
out with an army of doctors standing
behind him
to tell us everything is supposedly
great except that he didn't this was one
of the biggest
disasters in crisis management
he created a crisis by coming out and
obviously lying about how great
everything is going
it started to get weird with dr sean
connelly when he was asked whether
donald trump had been on
supplemental oxygen and conley insisted
trump didn't need
oxygen that day i'm gonna try to pin you
down one more time i know you said
there's no one yeah
yeah yeah he's not on oxygen but did he
uh today and he didn't receive any on
thursday and he's
what's today saturday uh no no thursday
no thursday no friday saturday that's
fine
that was why we were thursday no oxygen
none at this moment
yeah and yesterday with the team while
we were all here he was not on oxygen
so he says none thursday none at walter
reed friday
and none today which was saturday now of
course now we know
trump had oxygen friday at the white
house
really bad lying it was obvious that
sean connelly
was lying sean conley also mentioned and
this might be a case of accidentally
telling the truth
sean connelly mentioned trump had now
been this was saturday morning
conley said trump had been in treatment
72 hours
wait a second 72 hours from saturday
morning that puts us friday morning
thursday morning wednesday morning
publicly donald trump supposedly didn't
test positive till 1am friday morning
he's been in treatment for 72 hours
that's weird take a listen
as reported yesterday consultation with
this group
i recommended we bring the president up
to walter reed
as a precautionary measure to provide
state-of-the-art monitoring and any care
that he may need
just 72 hours into the diagnosis now the
first week of covid and a particular day
7-10 are the most critical
later conley put out a statement saying
i made a mistake
i just made a mistake about how long it
had been not very convincing for the
doctor who supposedly
has been involved in trump's treatment
every step of the way conley also said
trump had no fever for a while
minutes later we got a report that trump
had a fever that day
lies lies lies and when the pressure got
to be too much
when it became abundantly clear that
they were lying dr sean connelly came
out again on sunday
and seemed very confused about how time
works and what day it is
seeming to have uh almost of issues
better served for a physics lab uh that
than
than for a medical press conference how
does time work does it go forward or
backwards
only raising more questions about the
accuracy of the story that we are
getting here is connolly being asked
about
his vague admission that trump did have
some breathing problems but everything
is fine nonetheless
all right you said that there were two
instances where he had drops in oxygen
can you walk us through the second one
and also i've got a question for the
lung specialist afterwards sure yeah
yeah yesterday uh there was another
episode where he dropped down
about 93 percent um here's a never feel
short of breath
uh we watched it um and it returned back
up um as i said we evaluate all of these
and given the timeline where he is in
the the course of illness
you know we we're trying to maximize
everything that we could do for him and
we debated whether we'd even start it uh
the dexamethasone
and we decided that in this case the
potential benefits early on the course
probably outweighed any risks at this
time
did you give him a second round of
supplemental oxygen yesterday
uh i'd have to i'd have to check with
the nursing staff
i don't think that if he did it was very
very limited uh but
it's not on oxygen um and the only
oxygen that i ordered
that we provided was that friday morning
initially
and about what time was that yesterday
uh
yesterday what was yesterday you said
the second instance second
incidents oh it was over the course of
the day yeah yesterday morning
yesterday what oh yeah yesterday it was
during the course of the day
yesterday morning well wait hold on was
it in the morning or was it throughout
the day what are you talking about
even conley himself sounds confused like
he's
obviously lying like he's been told to
downplay
but he also seems confused about the
facts
in the next moment i'm going to play for
you
conley is called out for saying trump's
doing great and then minutes later
trump's chief of staff mark meadows came
out and admitted to the media
it's really bad we're not even sure
trump will make a full recovery at this
point in time
connolly called out about it and here's
how he how he responded
the steroids sir you told us that the
president was in great shape
had been in good shape and fever-free
for the previous 24 hours
minutes after your press conference
white house chief of staff mark meadows
told reporters that the president's
vitals were very concerning over the
past 24 hours
simple question for the american people
whose statements about the president's
health should be believed
so the chief and i work side by side
and i think his statement was
misconstrued what he meant
was that uh 24 hours ago
when he and i were are checking on the
president that there was that momentary
episode of the high
fever and and that temporary drop uh
in the saturation which prompted us to
act
uh expediently to move him up here
fortunately that was really a very
transient limited episode a couple hours
later he was back up
uh mild again um you know we i'm not
going to speculate what that
that limited episode was about so early
in the course but he's doing well
you really get the sense that conley is
just not cut out
for this lying he's doing the lying but
he's doing it really poorly and
transparently
nobody believes this guy at this point
check this one out remember from our
last segment
that oxygen saturation below 94
is sirius covid that's the baseline
conley is asked
was trump ever saturating oxygen below
90
and conley says we don't have recordings
of that
here at the hospital kind of a weird
response so then he's asked
was oxygen saturation ever below 90 and
conley says
it was never in the low 80s nobody asked
about the low 80s another
obvious lie never ever dipped below 90.
uh we don't have any recordings here of
that that's right
yeah what about here at the white house
or here anything below 90 just to follow
up on her question
uh no it was below 94 it was it wasn't
down in the low 80s or anything
so okay it's on the decks and methods it
is lie after lie
and from that what i interpret is
trump's saturation
did get to the 80s not the low 80s and
that's really serious covid
and then lastly here he is explaining
the previous days absurd rosy picture
that he painted
he just says well i was trying to be
upbeat
to disclose that the president had been
administered
oxygen uh it's a good question so
i was trying to reflect the the uh the
upbeat attitude that the
team the president this course of
illness has had
um didn't want to give any uh
any information that might steer the the
course of illness in another direction
um and in doing so uh you know it came
off
that we were trying to hide something
which wasn't necessarily true i love
that he says there i mean it's just
every sentence
every he says we weren't necessarily
trying to hide something
it's almost like a freudian use of the
word necessarily
you weren't necessarily trying to hide
something but you were
what does that even mean they lie about
everything
and we have to ask why and the answer is
optics
given that there's an election in 30
days or less i think it's what 29 days
at this point 28 days
period has donald trump gotten to the
point where they're going to send him
back to the white house you might
know more than i've been able to tell
you now because something may have
changed in the next few hours
we will follow it we will cover it they
are very very worried here
about the impact of this on the election
and we'll talk about that
after the break the david pakman show at
[Music]
davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches
from top quality materials and they just
look great
i went on their site and picked out a
watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in
mesh matte black and i love it it's
simple sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 percent off everything in
their store when you go to
davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's continue with our tour
of what was just
an incredible incredible weekend and i
have something for you that is not just
amazing it's also really smart
south carolina republican senator
lindsey graham we don't like lindsay
he has a serious challenger this year
it's democrat jamie harrison and the
polling
looks like this really could be a fight
i'll tell you that in a moment
lindsey graham also aside from being a
horrible senator has all sorts of
possible coronavirus exposure especially
now that tons of people at the white
house and around trump
have the virus so there was a debate
over the weekend lindsey graham versus
jamie harrison and jamie harrison
brought
his own plexiglas barrier to put around
himself to protect him from lindsey
graham's germs this is the perfect
combination
of being hilarious from like a visual
optics perspective
but also completely reasonable given the
irresponsibility of the republican party
and the fact that the virus is spreading
like wildfire
among republicans who are close to
donald trump chris christie has tested
positive
kellyanne conway has tested positive and
on and on
lindsey graham recently had contact with
republican senator mike lee
mike lee has tested positive and was at
that amy coney barrett
super spreader event in the white house
last saturday and so
uh he jamie harrison bringing his own
plexiglas
and that actually came up during the
debate check this out here's jamie
harrison
not judge barrett not the supreme court
you know
this has impacted me personally judy
my uh grand aunt gladys passed away this
july
in a nursing home by herself that is the
story that so many americans are
experiencing
right now and part of why we're
experiencing no
we're not going to blame the president
we shouldn't blame the president we
shouldn't blame anybody
for the the inception of this disease
but where blame should come
is how we handle this disease
whether or not we take it seriously you
know tonight i am taking it seriously
that's why i put this
plexiglass up because you know it's not
just about me
it's about the people in my life that i
have to take care of as well my two boys
my wife my grandmother
this debate was truly
a brutal drubbing by jamie harrison
of lindsey graham and it's south
carolina lindsey graham may well get
re-elected
but one of the best moments for jamie
harrison
and the worst for lindsey graham was
when jamie harrison went after lindsay
aggressively for being a complete and
total hypocrite
on the supreme court nomination of amy
coney barrett remember that lindsey
graham
back in 2016 when they held off uh
and suppressed and obstructed the
nomination of merrick garland lindsey
graham said hold me to it
even if this happens with trump we're
not doing it in the last year
and then now lindsey graham says amy
coney barrett yeah let's do it uh jamie
harrison calls him out and it's great
it reminds me of playing monopoly with
my son you change the rules that
he changes the rules every time he gets
you know senator you said
use my words against me and you said it
after the kavanaugh meetings not before
the kavanaugh hearings
after the kavanaugh hearings and your
words your promise was
that no judicial nominee should be
considered or approved or what have you
in the last
year of an election and you even named
president trump when you said it
and so this is my thing you know my
grandfather always taught me he said
jamie a man is only
as good as his word well senator how
good is your word when you made a
promise to the american people
and even more you made a promise to the
folks in south carolina that you
wouldn't be doing what you're doing
right now
and of course jamie harrison is 100
correct lindsey graham is a huge
hypocrite on this the republicans
haven't shown
that they care about hypocrisy but
lindsay is a massive hypocrite and it's
just a
really bad performance by lindsey graham
he seemed
rattled throughout a really funny moment
lindsey graham
seems perplexed here he seems visually
visibly perplexed about
where is the money coming from who are
these people donating money
to jamie harrison he simply can't
conceive of the idea
that a lot of people even in south
carolina just don't like him he thinks
it's some kind of democratic
conspiracy it's like no when people
don't like you
and they know you they often donate to
your opponent that's it
it was about ads and money
let's talk about money in politics where
the hell is all this money coming from
what is it about south carolina's
attracted almost 100 million
dollars into uh jamie harris and mr
harrison's coffers
they hate me this is not about mr
harrison this is about liberals hating
my guts
because i stood up for kavanaugh when
they tried to destroy his life
this is about me helping donald trump
the only good republican is one that
tries to undercut
trump i lost to president trump when i
ran for president if you don't remember
me running for president it's not your
fault
didn't last that long that is completely
right
it was crazy when lindsey graham went on
that lunatic rant defending brett
kavanaugh people don't like him because
of it many people
it has been ridiculous to watch lindsey
graham defend
anything that donald trump does while
always trying to pretend that he's
one of the reasonable republicans now
there is a real opportunity here
for lindsey graham to be defeated the
entire point of this segment
is to remind you there is an alternative
to lindsey graham in south carolina
yes jamie harrison is not the most
progressive of progressive democrats
yes he's been a south carolina
democratic party
insider for a while but we're talking
about removing
lindsey graham here and possibly taking
the senate
which would lead to actually getting
things done
if indeed joe biden is able to defeat
donald trump the latest polls out of
south carolina
you will notice we have polls from the
last six seven months or even more up on
the screen you'll notice this was not a
close race early the
in the year lindsey graham was up 13 and
17
in february but by july lindsey graham
was only up by seven
but the last four polls in this race
from august and september
are three ties and lindsey graham ahead
by
only one this is south carolina
my friends and a democratic challenger
could defeat a long-time incumbent
republican senator if you're looking at
a race to get involved in
phone banking or in other ways this is a
beautiful race
and uh when when we talk about you know
trump's not looking great in georgia
trump's not looking great in texas but
he'll he'll still win
but he may have to fight for it this is
one where
it really could just be a win for
democrats it's not just the benefit of
lindsay will have to spend money
defending his seat
that's great but we could actually go
for a win here we should do it
it could be the seat any one of these
close races could be the seat
that flips the senate two democrats
and uh this is one i would recommend you
get involved in
okay we now have received our first
post-debate
polling between donald trump
and joe biden and it is really really
bad for donald trump not so bad that we
can stay home
no we still have to vote but it is bad
a new nbc wall street journal poll has
donald trump
14 that is not a typo 14
points behind joe biden 53 to 39
among registered voters there's also an
ibd
poll which says it's biden only plus
three
there's a poll from the hill that has
biden plus seven
and there's a new cnbc poll that has
biden plus
13. those are the four post-debate polls
we had
as of this morning among those polls the
average biden lead is 9.3
the official real clear politics average
is biden plus
8.1 and this plus 14 for biden
in the nbc wall street journal poll is
almost
a doubling of biden's lead in that same
poll since the last time it was done
what's
very interesting about that particular
poll is that the nbc wall street journal
poll
tends to track the sort of average of
all polls so
if you have a range of polls saying uh a
candidate is anywhere from plus two to
plus ten and the average is five
usually the nbc poll is right in with
the average
that poll now says joe biden is winning
by 14.
so we really are seeing a difference
between 2016 and 2020 polling now
as i mentioned today october 5
joe biden is plus 8.1 on average back in
2016
on this date october 5 hillary clinton
was only ahead by 3.9
so of course we've got to be careful the
polls could be off
everybody has to vote voter suppression
etc but the idea
that the numbers now are just like 2016
is no longer true
uh joe biden's lead today is about 110
larger than hillary clinton's was in
2016. so what does that mean
it means we vote it means we try to make
those numbers a reality
it very much does not mean we can check
out and not worry
if donald trump does recover relatively
quickly from coronavirus
they will paint him as some kind of
heroic savior
they will push everything they can to
make the case that
strong hero trump is the person we need
they will suppress the vote they will do
all of it but right now
it's looking really bad for trump in the
meantime as another data point the 538
2020 projection
has slightly ticked up you'll remember
about a month ago joe biden had about a
70
chance to win it is now 81. does it
change anything about what we need to do
no a month ago in a hundred simulations
trump would win in 30.
now trump wins 19 but so what there's
still a one in five chance and it's too
great a risk
to become even one iota complacent at
this time
in terms of the popular vote again uh
rcp has it biden 8.1 ahead
538 has it biden 7.2 ahead that's big
for 538.
so now we vote the other question is
what will the trump covet diagnosis do
to the polling
anyone who would vote based on which
candidate
has coveted is already voting for trump
is my take
i don't believe trump's sycophants will
abandon him
because he got coveted i also don't
think trump is going to
gain sympathy voters because he got
coveted i think it cancels out
what you could have are people for whom
trump
getting coveted could be the final straw
in terms of trump's disregard for the
virus
those could be people who well abandoned
trump
over his complete mishandling of the
situation we may have polls today
or potentially tomorrow that are
post-trump's diagnosis
we will see what they say and we will
have those numbers for you
on our instagram make sure you're
following us on instagram
at david pakman show the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show so
the latest update i have
as of this moment and to not talk about
it would be weird but i have to
acknowledge that
things are moving very quickly and we
may have different news by the time you
listen to today's show is
the news is that donald trump may be
going home
soon today he may already be home or
maybe not
he still is scheduled to have a rally
tonight which i mean just
completely inconceivable obviously if he
did it it would be some kind of remote
thing he would be joining
via remote video donald trump of course
is not traveling
to a rally tonight but he's either doing
well or not doing well we just don't
know we are left to try to infer
and to try to wade through the lies but
one thing we have in black and white is
that this morning donald trump sent
20 20 consecutive completely manic
tweets in a very short period of time
from the hospital almost
all in capital letters and once again
this could be anything
is trump tweeting because he's panicked
that the latest polls are really bad
is he simply manic from the
dexamethasone
corticosteroid-induced mania is not an
uncommon side effect
of dexamethasone and other steroids we
just don't know
but the tweets are completely outrageous
take a look at just
some of these as you can see here donald
trump tweeting
most of these are all caps stock market
highs
vote virginia voters your governor wants
to obliterate your second amendment
i have stopped him if you want a massive
tax
increase the biggest in the history of
our country and one that will shut our
economy and jobs down vote democrat
i'm voting for donald trump my father is
a union worker and his 401k
has tripled under president trump uh
obviously
the stock market hasn't tripled so if
the 401k has tripled maybe the person
started contributing three times as much
sort of a non-sequitur
then just another string of all caps
tweets pro-life
vote massive regulation cuts vote space
force
vote best va ever 91
approval rating vote 401 k
vote biggest tax cut ever and another
one coming
vote religious liberty boat law and
order
vote peace through strength vote save
our second amendment
vote fight the corrupt fake news media
vote
protect pre-existing conditions vote
better and cheaper health care
so um completely out of control
uh could this be a combination
of a steroided up trump seeing the
latest nbc poll
which has them down by 14 points to joe
biden
and simply doing what he feels he can do
from a hospital our friend
farron cousins from ring of fire wrote
to me on twitter
most likely it's the steroids i've been
on them before
for severe asthma and they can make you
very angry and aggressive has someone
again lost control of trump it is
all speculation brought on by the
reality that trump's behavior doesn't
make any sense
and his doctors aren't being honest and
this administration hasn't been honest
about trump's health since day one
and trump lies about everything
dexamethasone rare side effect of the
drug
includes grandiose delusions
how would you be able to tell the
difference with this guy and some
experts have expressed concern
about the combinations of things trump
has gotten as you now know
trump received an unapproved antibody
cocktail
redesevere and endexamethazone
at minimum that we know of dr thomas
mcginn
from the new york state health provider
northwell
health said to the new york times that
the kitchen sink
is being thrown at donald trump and dr
vin gupta
said you don't start dexamethasone
remdessevere
and an antibody treatment that is yet
unapproved
if the president just slightly has a
lower oxygen level
you do it when there's covered pneumonia
or something more serious
will we ever know the truth i really
don't know we certainly don't know it
right now
and we've certainly never gotten the
truth on a whole bunch of other things
that have happened during the last four
years so we may never know
next we're going to talk about more
overt
doctoring of the tapes as the case may
be
so the propaganda games continue from
the white house they've now released a
video where it is all but completely
obvious that a violent cough by donald
trump has been edited out of the video
and done really poorly this is part of
the propaganda campaign that they've
been waging
since donald trump went to walter reed
hospital very quickly
they sat trump in front of a camera they
had him deliver what they claimed was a
one-take
very powerful four-minute video proving
how well he's doing and how strong he is
but it became immediately obvious
that at least at one point in this video
there is what appears to be a jump cut
something appears to be just cut out and
donald trump looks to be gagging
when it is done and the only logical
conclusion we can reach is that trump
coughing was removed from the video so
this
is i i acknowledge this is tough for our
audio audience you can find the video on
my twitter
i'm gonna first play the whole thing for
you and you'll notice that at the word
therapeutics
you hear something weird and you see
donald trump look almost like he's
gagging or dry heaving
but it's very very quick and it appears
to be a cough that was removed if you
look
closely you'll also see trump's fingers
jump
because they did a poor job of editing
out the cough
take a look if you look at the
therapeutics
which i'm taking right now some of them
so now let's actually isolate the moment
we're talking about
and play it without audio and again i
understand this is very visual
and that if you're only listening it's
hard to understand what what we're
seeing here but i did tweet this you can
find it on my twitter at the pacman
and as you can see trump seems to start
to gag or dry heave but then it
skips and trump's finger twitches and so
as usual the question is less about the
importance of this particular edit
and more about the constant gaslighting
of the american people to submit
uh to to force them to submit
to a completely fabricated and concocted
narrative
trump's case of coronavirus has been
stage managed
in a completely dishonest way for
optics and public relations appearances
christopher orr
is a contributing writer for the
atlantic and forbes tweeted that there
is clearly an
edit on this video experienced editors
are saying
that what is in adobe's suite called a
morph cut tool was used to remove
trump's violent cough from the video so
we need to be making sure
that we're asking the right questions
when we talk about something like this
why would the white house think they
have to do this
because of who trump supporters are
trump can't just be sick
from a serious virus that's not the
right story trump must be able to
deliver
four minutes of uncut narrative to the
audience
about how he's doing great trump must
not cough
because for seven months more than that
now eight months
he's been downplaying this as if it's no
big deal because if trump was
seriously ill it probably is the nail
in the coffin of the approval of trump
on coronavirus handling which is already
very very low
if even trump gets seriously ill who
could be the most protected person in
the world it also
goes to the laziness of this
administration
and of donald trump uh you could easily
cover this
by having trump stop go back one line
film it from a different angle like from
the side for example it would look like
a dramatic
filmmaking decision and no one would be
the wiser but they
insist or trump insists or trump is
refusing to redo it
they insist on doing the one take and
then
cutting it out cutting the cough out it
is the most childish
stage managing that we've seen not only
immoral to keep gaslighting the american
people about his condition
but also done in a very unprofessional
way it's a very
childish obvious detectable manner this
is what we've gotten handed to us
and this administration i guess thought
they could get away with it
they didn't and they still think that
they're going to get away with getting
this man re-elected
they may be right they may be wrong they
may be right it is ultimately up to us
to make sure that it doesn't happen and
that is why
none of this means anything other than
go and vote there is not every news
story
oh there's a conflict in armenia oh
trump's cutting out a cough from his
video
oh joe biden tested negative for
coronavirus a third time fortunately he
did
as of today it all means you go and you
vote
it all means you go to vote.org and you
figure out
am i voting early in person am i voting
by mail
am i voting on november 3rd if so where
what are the rules
can somebody tell me that i need to get
out of line what exactly
is the plan that's all that we have to
do we hear oh trump's attacking china
again
we gotta vote that is the one answer
here
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpakman.com that's join p
a k m a n dot com if the normal prices
strike you as high by all means use the
coupon code
vote soon 18 all one word all lower case
become a member today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
if we want to go back and ask the
question when
was donald trump first contagious for
coronavirus the answer is actually a
very scary one
because it likely was during the debate
with joe biden on tuesday fortunately so
far joe biden has had
uh it's either two or three negative
coronavirus tests and it's probably
another day or two before he would
be completely out of the woods due to
the incubation time during which
you would not yet test positive but what
we do know are the following
first of all donald trump lied about his
tests when donald trump was interviewed
on the sean hannity program thursday
night at 9 pm eastern
9 or 10 i believe 9 pm might be 10 10pm
that was before his 1am announcement of
testing positive he said i've been
tested and i'm waiting for the results
but in reality
donald trump had already had a positive
rapid test at that time he had had a
positive test
and was waiting on results from a second
pcr
test trump already had a positive test
but pretended that he had not
then donald trump's doctor talked on
saturday morning
said we're 72 hours in which puts us at
wednesday morning
and then later the doctor said no no no
i misspoke that's not true but already
very weird
and then fox news's chris wallace who
was the debate moderator last tuesday
between donald trump and joe biden said
well
you know how everybody was tested at the
debate hall
well turns out trump wasn't really
tested trump showed up late
and we went on the honor system that he
had tested negative
check this out was that i arrived on
sunday i think you arrived on monday
they didn't arrive till tuesday
afternoon so
for them to get tested uh there wouldn't
have been enough time to have the test
and have the debate at nine o'clock that
night they didn't show up
until three four five o'clock in the
afternoon so
yeah there was an honor system when it
came to the people that came into the
hall from the two campaigns
so in reality trump might have been
positive
at that time and known it so they
deliberately showed up late to avoid the
test but even
without that idle speculation there's a
bigger reality
according to dr ashish jha dean of the
brown university school of public health
based on the timeline that they admit to
trump likely was infected between
saturday
and monday that points to the amy coney
barrett
super spreader event i'm talking about
not this previous saturday but the one
before it
takes five days on average for the virus
to be detected from the point of view of
an infection
and then it can remain detectable for up
to 14 days
with some exceptions on average
coronavirus remains
undetected for around five days after
the point of infection
which means that trump likely was
infected and likely contagious
on tuesday although fortunately as far
as
at least on stage he didn't go near joe
biden
and indeed so far joe biden has tested
negative multiple times after the debate
chris wallace was also on stage with
them and he says he will get tested
but is waiting because his doctor told
him early on
you could get a false negative take a
look at what chris wallace had to say
minutes uh you've got some people
testing positive
senator mike lee who we've learned was
at the white house earlier this week
can you maybe umbrella all of this for
us with what we should be watching for
well i'm going to tell you what my
doctor is telling me
which raises some some questions for me
and you know i
i'm i'm only going to tell you what my
doctor is telling me but it does raise
some questions about the timeline
because i'm gonna have to get a test i'm
in a uh
uh in a uniquely vulnerable circle
the three people on the stage for an
extended period with the president
and the vice president and me all
without masks
uh and and my doctor is telling me that
i shouldn't get a test today
because it takes five days for the virus
to load up
enough and that i could have a test but
it might well be a false negative
the significance of that to me is that
if the president had a test yesterday
uh and it tested positive then i think
he had the coronavirus
during the debate because you know this
talk about well he was with hope hicks
on the plane
in minnesota on wednesday i don't think
you'd have a positive test and again
i'm not a doctor i'm simply telling it
in terms of what i was told by my doctor
uh you it wouldn't load up enough to
have a
definitive positive test uh on
uh for about four or five days which is
why i'm not getting tested until next
monday
so chris wallace actually making
absolute and total sense here now why is
chris wallace in a studio saying this
shouldn't wallace also be quarantining
if he may have been exposed
and has not yet had a negative test just
asking but
overall it is a trail of incompetence
and chaos that follows donald trump
his actions and decisions and behaviors
are
disastrous everywhere he goes and this
actually makes trump's criticism of joe
biden
during the debate for wearing a mask a
big mask
it makes it even more immoral and
ridiculous remember this
i don't i don't wear mess like him every
time you see him he's got a mask he
could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
well we now know that at the same time
that donald trump was laughing at chris
at
joe biden for wearing a big mask
and having small crowds at his events
and so on and so forth in all likelihood
donald trump was contagious at that
time how insane is this situation
and we've better hope that joe biden
does not end up
testing positive it again it doesn't
chris wallace announced at the start of
the debate the candidates have agreed
not to shake hands at the end of the
debate they did not approach each other
at one point it sort of seemed like
donald trump was going to approach joe
biden and if you watch that moment again
you can't really tell but it's possible
that melania trump held him back
who knows what melania trump knew at the
time about trump's coronavirus status
because they won't answer questions such
as
when was trump's latest negative test
they won't tell us kaylee mcinanni has
said she's not going to tell us because
of privacy reasons if you can imagine
we simply do not know and are left to
speculate
how insane is this situation let's talk
a little bit more about chris wallace
now
so let me set up this next segment for
you i already told you
chris wallace was likely on stage with a
contagious trump
during tuesday's debate based on the
timeline we
understand that in all likelihood donald
trump contracted coronavirus
either sometime between saturday and
monday of the previous week
uh and was likely contagious during the
debate as i already told you donald
trump was not tested at the debate as
most people
as everybody was supposed to be they
showed up late and were allowed to use
the honor system
to tell them trump doesn't have
coronavirus i already told you last week
during a stream
that donald trump's family immediately
took off their masks
at the debate the only people in the
debate hall to do so
even though the rules were keep the
masks on
so this weekend cnn fox news sunday you
know all of these different sunday shows
they tried to get trump administration
people on to talk about what's going on
no one agreed to do it except one senior
adviser to trump named steve cortez
who went on fox news sunday with chris
wallace and it devolved into
base utter lunacy that we really should
be studying and teaching our children so
they don't grow up to be like steve
cortez
let's start with chris wallace asking
why
doesn't the trump family think the rules
apply to them
with the masks and cortez is immediately
being deceptive not apply to them no
that's not the reality look
everybody was tested before that event
as you well know uh those of us who went
first were tested by cleveland clinic
directly everybody who gets on air force
one for any trip on air force one
is tested before they get on it doesn't
matter steve it doesn't matter everybody
that was in that room was test
steve everybody that was in that room
was tested
and the cleveland clinic's regulation
was it didn't matter
everybody except for the three of us on
the stage was to wear a mask
and people from the cleveland clinic
came over
and offered the first family mass
thinking maybe they didn't have them
they were waved away
and the commission on presidential
debates has issued a statement saying
from now on if you don't wear a mask
you're going to be escorted from the
hall
so chris wallace is rightly upset there
because
he and biden may have been exposed at
the debate
but when cortes says listen everybody on
air force one is
tested remember trump showed up too late
to be tested
and they took trump's word that he was
negative and now we know trump may well
have been positive at the time
and was almost certainly contagious
according to multiple doctors even on
the basic
facts this trump advisor
i don't know about camp but won't be
honest let's continue
so forget this question of being tested
beforehand everybody was tested
beforehand
that no i'm going to finish my question
everybody was told to wear a mask why
did the first family and the chief of
staff feel
that the rules for everybody else didn't
apply to them
chris we believe that masks are very
useful the president has warned them on
many occasions including visiting
the hospital where he's now a patient
when he was visiting as
commander-in-chief as a guest to visit
soldiers there he wore a mask we believe
in mass we also believe in some element
of individual choice people were
distanced
and they had been tested this is all you
know
me me me we believe in choice we believe
in masks that those aren't the questions
the question is the debate hall had
rules
why why did the trump family just ignore
them
now there is shared blame here the first
family
should have been kicked out and it was
the debate organizers and the venue that
didn't do it and i understand that
that's a difficult thing to do would
have had
major pr repercussions despite being the
right thing to do now
the debate commission has been forced to
say if there are future debates at this
point we don't know trump is coronavirus
if you don't wear a mask you are going
to be kicked out
but the guy simply can't answer a simple
question
now notice what happens next when steve
cortez
can't get away from the question why did
they break the rules
he switches to attacking chris wallace
both of those things were true in that
game
they weren't distanced and there were
rules and there was no there was no
freedom of choice they broke the prison
i was there
i was there like you were and they were
distanced why did they break not close
together
look those chairs were not close
together and again we also believe that
people it doesn't matter
the rules from the individuals were
close together steve and the rules from
the cleveland clinic where
everybody wears a mask why didn't they
just chris the way you're starting to
harangue me now actually reminds me of
what you did to the president
during that debate on tuesday night not
just
no did you see what he did there he goes
after chris wallace he says listen chris
you're haranguing me just like you did
to trump
you unfair moderator from fox news
of course when you lose on the facts
you go ad hominem this is a very typical
thing
that happens in debates when people lose
on the facts and it continues
and chris wallace just re starts reaming
out steve cortez
and then he had that he had to debate
not just joe biden but you
as well you were not a neutral moderator
then i don't mind tough questions i
welcome
reasonably talk questions but what i
don't think is okay is for you to become
the effective opposition to the
president
okay and those everyone there was tested
in the crowd they were distanced from
each other
people can make reasonable decisions for
themselves state
no they actually they can't they're the
rules and they'll be kicked out next
time
steve let me just simply say the
president interrupted me and the vice
president 145 times so i object to
saying
i harangue the president i know it's the
talking point so the problem is that
while wallace
what what wallace says is true trump did
interrupt more than a hundred times
this is actually about the rules of the
debate hall it's not
what don jr's assessment of the distance
between
chairs is that doesn't matter and
unfortunately trumpists will fall for
this when you ask
trumpists i haven't seen it done yet but
based on
the vigil they held with no masks
outside walter reed over the weekend
if you went to trumpus and you said what
about this why did the trump family pull
the you know that's wrong they took
their masks off they would say
there was lots of space and we believe
in masks when people are crowded
together
but they weren't crowded to get it
together the people who claim to be all
about law and order
are going to say well you know the rules
we decide if we want to follow the rules
or if the rules make sense or whatever
doesn't really sound like law and order
to me i assure you
they see this and they end up mad at
chris wallace
not at dishonest steve cortez the lying
trump advisor
not at the trump family for not wearing
masks not at trump for
making fun of joe biden's mask while
likely contagious with coronavirus
himself while on the stage
now the practical question is whether
there will be more debates
this week wednesday night is the kamala
harris versus mike pence vp debate
every indication is that's going to
happen although they've agreed to more
space between
harris and pence on the stage i would
love to see kamala harris bring her own
plexiglas mike pence was at the amy
coney barrett super spreader event
sitting next to people who got the virus
i would be careful if i was kamala
harris
then we get to debates number two and
three for trump and biden
now the first one is scheduled for ten
days from today
uh trump has coronavirus as of today
that that's what we know you know what
they claim tomorrow i don't know but at
least as of today trump has coronavirus
trump's going to travel in 10 days or
even nine days if he's supposed to go
the day before
to a debate on an airplane
and again be on stage with joe biden and
the moderator
just 10 days after being in the hospital
for coronavirus
i don't see it so i don't know if the
idea is maybe they will go remote i
don't know
what the thought is at this point there
may be no more debate debates
they may be video conference debates
maybe the second one gets cancelled and
they skip to the third which is an
additional week down the line
17 days from today it's anyone's guess
at this point in time we'll follow it
and let you know as we learn more about
it
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p here is a great question
about
what would trump be doing now if the
situation were reversed take a listen to
this
what would they do if the circumstances
were reversed
and biden were sick they would move in
for the kill
i think right i think that there's a
parallel between the number of people
that trump has allowed to get sick and
the fact that he allowed himself
and his people in his entourage to get
sick it just goes to show
he's unfit and they would show no mercy
if the situation
were reversed so maybe you want to do a
show about that
there is absolutely no question about it
you know joe biden when donald trump
was was positive for coronavirus
immediately announced he was pulling
negative ads
that he was sending his best wishes
barack obama sent best wishes you even
had anchors like on msnbc talking about
trump's new tone and all of this stuff
and meanwhile as donald trump is being
airlifted to walter reed hospital
amid a cloud of dishonesty and and uh
confusion about his actual condition the
trump campaign is sending out
fundraising emails
about lion's sleepy joe and all of this
insane
conspiratorial nonsense that they email
people about all the time
trump is back on twitter already it is
abundantly clear
that joe biden has done everything right
joe biden's campaign events abide by the
cdc guidelines
joe biden despite having been on stage
with what was likely a contagious trump
during that first debate
has fortunately as of this moment of
recording tested negative for
coronavirus three times
joe biden just needs to keep running a
campaign period
and you know negative that he's going to
run positive ads but not negative ads
criticizing trump on policy is fair game
we have an election someone is going to
be president the next four years
and i think that it is if if it was
reversed just imagine
they would be running ads saying weak
biden got the virus
masks don't work because biden wore a
big mask and got the virus anyway
imagine if you got it from trump while
being on stage during a moment where
supposedly everybody on stage had been
tested and tested negative
they would be running negative ads they
wouldn't stop anything there is no
question about it i don't think there is
anything wrong with joe biden simply
continuing to campaign
we have a great bonus show for you today
what's going to happen with the
confirmation of amy coney barrett
as a result of trump testing positive
because it's not just trump
mike lee and two other republican
senators ron johnson
and one more i forget the name have
tested positive
if they can't be there plus murkowski
and collins
won't vote before the election they
don't have the votes
so we are going to talk about that and
more and more things are pointing to the
lame duck period
regal cinemas is closing all cinemas
in the united states and the united
kingdom on thursday
are we seeing the beginning of the end
of the movie theater industry
and lastly 11 positive coronavirus tests
have now been traced
specifically to the presidential debate
according to cleveland officials we are
going to talk about
whether they will have any ability to
enforce the rules
if debates number two and three happen
and of course
at the vice presidential debate which
still as of right now
and things changed so quickly which is
why i say it that way as of right now
is still scheduled for this wednesday
night at 9 00 pm eastern time if indeed
the debate happens wednesday night the
vp debate
i will be streaming live on youtube
twitch and facebook
i hope you will join me for what i think
will be
an absolute brutalizing of mike pence
by kamala harris
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's program
was made possible by vincero
watches the american watchmaker building
super quality wrist watches but making
them affordable for everyday people
and they're giving you fifteen percent
off when you go to davidpakman.com
vincero today's show also sponsored by
blinkist blinkist is the app that lets
you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book
in 15 minutes and you can try blinkist
for free and get 25 off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put that link down
below
underneath the video